todos aquí estamos familiarizados con el
sistema numérico base 10 al que
generalmente llamamos sistema decimal
que a fin de cuentas se llama base 10
porque tiene estos 10 símbolos el 0 el 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y el 9 ahora en el vídeo
pasado le echamos un vistazo rápido al
sistema base 2 también llamado sistema
binario que únicamente utiliza el 0 y el
1 y aquí en estos lugares
en lugar de tener potencias de 10 como
tenemos en el sistema decimal en el
sistema binario un sistema numérico base
2 los valores de cada lugar corresponden
a las potencias de 2 ok también por eso
se llama sistema base 2 si ponemos un 1
en este lugar significa que tenemos 1 de
este 2 a la 4 que es un 16 pero bueno el
chiste es que para cualquier número que
se nos ocurra podemos hacer un sistema
numérico con base en ese número aunque
podríamos tener un sistema numérico base
es un sistema numérico base 9 incluso
podríamos tener bases más grandes que 10
o sea hasta podríamos tener un sistema
numérico base 999 pero mejor quedémonos
con los ejemplos más sencillos ok en
este vídeo yo quiero exponerte a un
sistema numérico muy utilizado en cosas
en las que ni te imaginas que se está
utilizando no hay forma de que te des
cuenta pero todos los días que te metes
a internet estás usando indirectamente
este sistema numérico así es que vamos a
ver el sistema numérico base 16
hace 10 y 6 también llamado hexadecimal
extra de sí
y como te puedes imaginar en lugar de
tener dos dígitos o 10 dígitos pues este
sistema base de 16 va a tener 16 dígitos
y aquí en lugar de tener potencias de 2
o potencias de 10 vamos a tener
potencias de 16 ahora cuáles van a ser
esos 16 dígitos pues podemos reciclar
estos primeros 10 dígitos en sistema
numérico decimal así es que tenemos 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y luego pues nos faltan
todavía otros 6 dígitos ahora ya hay una
convención mundial que dice que los
siguientes 6 dígitos del sistema
hexadecimal son las primeras seis letras
del abecedario
así es que aquí tenemos que poner
ve
d
efe y entonces pues tú puedes decir oye
sal pero cómo está eso de que ahora las
letras son números y entonces yo te
puedo decir recuerda que todos estos son
simplemente unos garabatos que nosotros
hacemos con pluma encima de los papeles
ok se nos podría haber ocurrido un
montón de garabatos que poner por aquí
pero es muchísimo más fácil ponernos de
acuerdo mundialmente con estas letras
ahora dentro de este sistema hexadecimal
cada que veas una a no tienes que estar
pensando en esa letra que te recuerda no
sé a alguien diciendo ah
ok está lo que representa es un 10 y
cuando veas esta vez en términos del
sistema numérico hexadecimal tampoco
estamos pensando en la letra d en sí
sino que estamos pensando en el número
11 ok y la letra se representa el número
12 la letra d representa el número 13 la
letra
representa el número 14 y la letra f
representa al número 15 ahora siempre
que tengas 10 cosas puedes decir tengo a
cosas en el sistema extra de cimas o en
lugar de decir hoy es viernes 13 puedes
decir hoy es viernes d en el sistema
hexadecimal y en lugar de decir tengo 12
canicas puedes pensar que tienes sé
canicas y en lugar de 15 cosas tienes
efe cosas ahora veamos si podemos
escribir esta cantidad que es 231 en el
sistema decimal pero ahora en términos
del sistema hexadecimal y lo que vamos a
hacer es que voy a decirte de una vez
cómo
escribe esta cantidad en términos del
sistema hexadecimal y después vamos a
ver que realmente estas cantidades son
equivalentes utilizando los valores del
lugar y convirtiendo este número que te
voy a dar al sistema decimal a ver yo
digo que 231 en el sistema decimal
se escribe como
7 en el sistema hexadecimal tal vez
sientas que esto se ve muy loco como si
estuviéramos jugando submarino o algo
así pero no este es tal cual el número
231 escrito en el sistema numérico
hexadecimal ahora vamos a descifrar cuál
es la cantidad es 7
ok este lugar es el lugar de hasta la
derecha que si nos fijamos en el sistema
binario correspondía a 2 a la 0 o sea a
los 12 y en el sistema decimal era 10 a
la 0 que también eran los unos así es
que en el sistema hexadecimal este es el
lugar de los 16 a la 0 o sea de los unos
12 y ahora podemos pasar a este otro
lugar que tiene un valor de 16 a la 1
aquí el segundo valor en el sistema
binario era 2 a la 1 y en el sistema
decimal era 10 a la 1 así es que lo más
lógico es que este lugar tenga un valor
de 16 a la 1
o sea que este número representa cuántos
16 es tenemos entonces este es el lugar
de los 16 es
esta es en este lugar nos dice que
tenemos a 16 es no tenemos una palabra
tan bonita como decenas para denotar
grupos de 16 cosas pero eso es lo que
queremos decir con esto de los 16 es
entonces este número literalmente en el
sistema extra decimal significa que
tenemos 16 6
16s
10 6
unos ahora la verdad es que nosotros
pensamos mucho más en el sistema decimal
entonces cuando vemos esto
inmediatamente pensamos que él es el
número 14
14 y entonces si tenemos 14 16 es en
realidad lo que tenemos es 14 por 16 más
7 unos que significa 7 por 1 que es
simplemente 17 ahora 14 16 6 que es lo
mismo que 14 por 16 es igual a 224 que
más 7 es igual a 231 entonces acabamos
de ver que es 7 en el sistema
hexadecimal es igual a 231 en el decimal
y también acabamos de ver un ejemplo de
cómo pasar de un número extra decimal a
un número decimal pero bueno el chiste
de este asunto es que cualquier número
como 231 que puedas escribir en el
sistema decimal también lo puedes
escribir en el sistema binario o en el
sistema extra decimal o en el sistema
base 295
o en el sistema base de 999.999
y cualquier número que puedas escribir
en alguno de estos sistemas numéricos
puedes escribirlo en cualquiera de los
otros sistemas numéricos y tal vez hayas
encontrado algún patrón en estas tres
formas de escribir el mismo número si te
fijas entre más dígitos tiene nuestro
sistema numérico más chico se ve el
número ok utilizamos menos cifras para
denotar la misma cantidad y eso es
porque entre más dígitos tengas en tu
sistema numérico cada uno de los lugares
de valor te puede dar más información
ok únicamente con esta cifra el sistema
hexadecimal me puede dar una cantidad
entre 0 y 15 mientras que el sistema
binario con una cifra únicamente puede
representar una cantidad entre 0 y 1 y
eso es algo que se vuelve más acentuado
entre más cifras tengamos o sea por
ejemplo aquí vamos a tener 16 al
cuadrado que es 252 entonces en este
lugar
estar contando de 100 en 100 vamos a
estar contando de 256 en 256 y como
puedes ver entre más grande sea la base
vas a poder expresar números mucho más
grandes con menos cifras bueno espero
que disfrutes el sistema hexadecimal
tanto como yo y además este sistema
hexadecimal es súper útil o sea la
mayoría de las páginas de internet si
tuvieras acceso al código con el cual
construye en la página podrías ver que
utilizan el sistema hexadecimal para
decir de qué color son cada una de las
cosas que están en la página de internet
ok
porque los colores pueden tener
distintos niveles de intensidad o sea
puedes tener un rojo muy claro o puedes
tener un rojo muy oscuro y entonces
cuando quieres ponerle color a cierto
pedazo de la página tienes que escoger
que el nivel de intensidad va a llevar
en lugar de poner color rojo 255 puedes
simplemente poner color
efe efe que es una cifra más corta ahora
piensa en qué número está representando
a efe 3 no es que este número sea muy
importante pero es un buen ejercicio